[Music]
well I want to thank Dirk for a
wonderful introduction and and it makes
my talk immensely easier because I can
concentrate on how we did it and he
showed you a lot of what we did I'd like
to say one or two things about about or
engines bill is correct that we missed
out on the Golden Age we heard so much
about yesterday we've been writing at
least one proposal a year since about
nineteen sixty two and the first
proposals were for a hundred and forty
MeV machine and we were in internal
competition for tandem vandegraaff and
this went on for several years where
Vander graphs were put in other
universities and 140 MV machines were
put in national laboratories and there
was about 1964 a caucus in which it was
decided to go after a 500 MeV linic if
you can't get 140 so try for 500 and
through the help of Arthur Kerman Herman
Feshbach our theoretical friends it was
decided to go after only an electron
machine and we heard from Fred yesterday
that in 1966 we got a phone call saying
would you settle for half and we have
been settling for something like that
for ever since now bill mentioned Peter
Deimos fill sergeant Stan Kowalski
myself as people who were frustrated at
the
kind of machinery that was available and
who were pressing the issue and when the
money was appropriated it became urgent
to get a couple of professionals one in
accelerator design that was Jacobsen and
he came for a few years the other was an
expert in wheeling and dealing and
haggling and that was Paul Reardon he
also came for a few years got us rolling
and what we built and what we've
operated for a long time is indicated
here I'd like to tell you a few things
about it I'll use my time I won't go
through the whole story not not
conceivably now what you notice is that
there's been a huge traffic through that
place in a lot in those years
seventy-five graduate students who have
got their PhD theses that is probably
our most important product those are the
Bates babies you'll hear from one in the
next lecture and Dirk mentioned that now
that work has been carried out by a very
small number of people this is the
present distribution I don't expect you
to remember any of this but I'd like to
point out a number of things if you look
at the distribution you'll notice that
the academic staff research staff and
graduate students overwhelming numbers
or at least are equal to the so-called
support staff and you wonder how can you
do that kind of thing
well what you have to do is you have to
have a support staff which is as
talented as the graduate students and
the research staff and
if you have then a hundred very talented
people who work very hard you can do a
lot of stuff and that's that's the way
the place works with smart people
working very hard there is a consequence
however the organization chart that Fred
showed you may be the way it looks from
the dean's office but on the floor this
is what it looks like it's a conference
among peers I defy you to find the
director in there I've worked with two
directors and for each of them that's
been the organization chart we have a
new management since November I'd be
interested to see a few years from now
whether that still applies you might
notice that that that salt also looks
like a theory seminar at MIT one other
thing that's been remarked upon is that
over the years the generations look
younger and younger especially you
notice it when the freshman class comes
in and that's the truth but at MIT at
Bates the situation is even more absurd
this is another flans instructing his
elders now okay
there is a opportunity to visit Bates
tomorrow it's open house and the
laboratory is about 25 25 miles north of
the city MIT is about 25 miles this way
cranes beach and Plum Island is about 10
miles that way
and it is a very gorgeous campus it is
on campus according to MIT
administration the laboratory is named
after William Bates
it was the congressional representative
from that district who helped us get
that land at a very crucial time the
laboratory schematically is shown here
color-coded with the code indicated at
the bottom showing how it's grown over
the years
the original proposal contemplated all
of that except for the ring out here
which is the project presently underway
it was for five hundred MeV to supply a
high-resolution spectrometer and a
coincidence capability now when we had
to settle for for half there was
convened in 1967 summer study in which
all the options were vigorously debated
Berto Singh was a forceful presence
through throughout that out of it
emerged and and it was a joint seminar
with the people at SAC clay who were
building machine at the same time they
however were not financially embarrassed
they built both sides we decided to
build a high resolution facility for
electron scattering
now very roughly the beam energy now
goes up to a GeV it's it was that was
accomplished by taking the beam and
recirculating it once one more time this
was a project that was undertaken by
Phil Sargent and Jeff lands and Stan
Kowalski and has been successful high
currents one percent duty one percent
duty factor and the work I'll show you
has been done mainly with that we are
presently engaged in an upgrade it's
been referred to as the South Hall ring
experiment at the end of that we expect
to have approximately 100 percent Duty
factor with the other parameters more or
less the same now for those of you who
won't make the trip let me show you some
pictures here's a view of the
accelerator looking at it from the
injector it's not quite as infinite as
slack but it's all a matter of
perspective
here's a picture of the same thing now
with at a later time with the
recirculate or magnets are installed
they're not really that big that's a
matter of perspective but those are
surplus from University of Michigan
those of you who make the trip will
notice that at least half of the
hardware around there is hand-me-downs
from one place or another that's one way
of coping with poverty we have produced
and had an operating a complement of
spectrometers I just list them here this
is the high-resolution one big project
to the 60s and early 70s
Burt Ozzie Kowalski Williamson Sargent
myself the medium energy Payan
spectrometer Ingvar bloom Fisk Aaron
Bernstein the RPI group Oh hips Jim
Matthews and her associates
Big Bite Claud Williamson Edie booth
with a PI zero spectrometer and now
these have all been operating now we're
in the process of building something
called an outer plane
proton spectrometer system let me show
you some pictures
there's the high-resolution
spectrometers system l see here these
are three of four magnets of a chicane
which allows us to do electron
scattering at precisely 180 degrees
which is important if you want to get
the magnetization densities that Dirk
was talking about this is a project that
was funded by the by the government do
we are hurt or one of those outfits and
done by the University of Massachusetts
jerry peterson and jay flans who was a
graduate student there that was his
thesis that's an example one good
example another thing that makes the
laboratory viable in spite of the small
numbers and that's the contributions of
the users this is a good example and
that system worked beautifully there's
one further remark that some of you may
recognize is Bill lobar who claims to do
everything and that's proof these are
coincident spectrometers in the South
Hall this is the one this is MEPs this
is all hips this one was designed by
Ingvar Bloomquist and this one was built
out of surplus magnets and here's
schematically what the other plain
spectrometer system will look like this
is the hips and here are four quadruple
dipole combinations whose intent will be
to measure the out of plane coincidence
protons from proton knockout and in fact
one of these has already been built and
tested and used in an experiment the
first ever measurement of the so-called
v response function this was using
polarized electrons on a carbon and
deuterium target and measuring the
angular distribution out of the plane
of the NA crowd protons this is an
experiment that was jointly done by a
University of Illinois group were
working under Papa Nicholas and and
Gilberto Z's group at MIT now why did we
initially settle for just a
high-resolution spectrometer well you
must remember the time the time was the
early 60s middle 60s when shell model
was and and the mean field was in the
process of being developed there was a
lot of interest in how can the nucleus
coexist as a collective manifest
collective properties and how does that
come out of out of the motion of
nucleons in a mean field how was that
all that story put together and the
available data were mainly moments the
integrals over the radial wave functions
the form factors give you the
distributions now there were some data
and they were enticing but they were
very fragmentary and the reason was
twofold
one the available currents were very
small one micro amp was a terrific
current and the resolutions were awful
the best was 10 to the minus 3 and that
was insufficient to resolve very
interesting states so what was done was
to build a system that would use every
electron that the accelerator
accelerator would provide it in the case
of the Bates accelerator it was like 10
to the minus 3 and designed the system
so that you could do resolution you
could achieve resolution in the electron
scattering of 10 to the minus 4 or
better it's a very wonderful project
work beautifully as I will show you here
is a very good example of the kind of
thing that can be done has been done the
reason why the resolution is so
important here is Gatling gun only in
154 where previous spectroscopy had
indicated that the low lying states
could be described as a mix of a
rotational band K equals 0 where is this
beta vibrational band in a gamma wrote
the vibrational band and the
high-resolution was important for two
reasons one of course is to separate the
states the second if you look at the 0
plus beta and the 2 plus beta if the
resolution were not very good you
wouldn't see that coming out of the out
of the background so those two major
motivations
so here our transition densities the
first based on the of the two three two
plus States the rotational state at the
top the beta vibration in the in the
middle and the gamma vibration at the
bottom and as you can see the location
of those distributions beautifully
support the collective description at
the same time of course there was and
had been underway very extensive set of
calculations by John negli and many of
his collaborators on the microscopic
description of these transitions and
here is the ground state density for the
same nucleus one is theoretical and the
other is experimental and the
differences are not visible in a display
like this but they are in the region
that I've indicated in color now there
is of course by this time several
thousand spectra form factors in all
regions of the periodic table here for
example is a series of I so density
distributions in the same region of the
periodic table as I just showed you and
up until yesterday I had the impression
that the theoretical activity had more
or less subsided in this area but I was
happy to hear from Steve Koonin that
there is now a new initiative to refine
further the the mean field it would be
very interesting to see whether there
the more vigorous computers can cope
with data of this kind dirk showed you
some data on on the lead region which I
will therefore skip and move to what has
been a preoccupation in the laboratory
for the last or last decade maybe and it
has to do with the connection between
the nucleon nucleon force and the
current in the nucleus in a oh there we
go the nucleon nucleon force generally
is understood in its longest range to be
the exchange of a PI on and that PI on
should manifest itself if it's charged
in a current and that current should be
detectable in an electron scattering
experiment this is a the first statement
that there that should be manifested as
a current which should be detectable was
pointed out by Felix Vilar's
in the late 40s and it is taken until
just recently for that to be come sorted
out in a very systematic and almost
believable way the
president agenda in in in in nuclear
physics is summarized here and in order
to get at those questions there is
imposed on us a number of experimental
requirements that we have been
systematically working to achieve you
have to if you want the short range you
need high q-- high q implies low
cross-section which therefore
experimentally implies high luminosity
product of luminosity solid angle and
detection this should be epsilon
detection efficiency you want to do the
coincidence experiments at once that
implies a duty factor many of the
interesting amplitudes are small and
have to be extracted in a interference
experiment that implies spin in the beam
target and the recoil and because one is
getting at the fundamentals you want to
use simple targets by simple meaning few
hadrons like the deuteron and the
helium-3 and the Triton experimentally
of course that theoretical simplicity
comes very expensive now to get the
polarized beam there was as Derek
mentioned as frequently happens an
experiment gets started you produce some
piece of hardware specifically for that
experiment and it turns out to be
generally applicable for for a long
range program so an investment that may
appear to be large for one small
experiment extended over the life of a
program is per year or however you want
to measure it not bad at all and the
polarized electrons appeared in the
laboratory
from Vernon Hughes and and Paul Sauter
and Mike LaBelle and and the students
from Yale who scattered around too and
and with the work of Stan Kowalski and
George Dotson we undertook to measure
the interference between the photon
exchange and the Z exchange in the
elastic scattering of carbon-12 we
measured this D asymmetry left
polarization - right polarization of the
electrons the nuclear-nuclear form
factor drops out and one gets this
interference term directly the polarized
source once again funded by dio e
construction started and carried almost
a completion that at Yale and brought to
that debates and installed here is a
picture of it the experiment very simple
there is the entire laboratory there's
the injector there's the accelerator
beam lines detector systems all
requiring careful control on the
systematics because the effect is very
small of the order of fractional parts
per million here's a the statistics on
the data that's the right - left
asymmetry that's a Gaussian over that
number of orders of magnitude one is
confident in the statistics systematic
errors
these are the final errors these are in
parts-per-million
and there was a correction which at one
stage was a source of considerable
despair but which finally understood and
was that big yielding a final result
final experimental result 0.6 plus or
minus 0.1 for statistics plus or minus
0.02 parts per million which yields this
factor gamma twiddle experimentally is
this in terms of the standard model it's
directly proportional to sine squared
theta is w and this is the number given
the best available value of sine squared
theta and there certainly consistent but
not a good measure now of that
electroweak factor how much time 0 0
okay well let me not be tempted to take
a few minutes just to talk about another
program I think the point I wanted to
make has been clearly made not
particularly in the in the specifics
that I would like to have gone to but it
has been I think and continues to be
very exciting program we are in the
process
a building this Southall ring which we
expect to finish sometime this year
already injection experiments have
started in putting electrons along this
line this porcupine here is the blast
detector which is another one of these
things where there are large numbers of
people willing to commit substantial
fraction there are young lives to make
build and work and to run what is the
state of the blast detector
well last PA C there were a number of
experimental programs approved time
assigned even though the detectors not
built I forget whether that's three or
five thousand hours of beam time that's
been approved technical panels have
reviewed it and I think it's a good
thing can be built and there's the right
crew to build it do we had a scientific
review and the deal we reviewers think
it's a nice project we have yet however
to hear about money which brings us back
to where we began about the golden age
the original proposals we wrote for sort
of five pages long these are voluminous
and I guess I'll quit there except for
one soundbite which I owe to fill
sergeant when the laboratory was
approved it was called a five million
dollar mistake and we tried to make it
run a few years later and it wouldn't
work it was called a joke and I think
I've given you considerable evidence
that is really a miracle thanks for your
attention
you